Just like flowers, we humans are also fully
capable of producing Volatile Organic Compounds.
Hey there flowering buds, Jules here for DNews!
As you know, plants are usually anchored to
the ground and can’t go anywhere.
But somehow, despite their relative immobility,
plants are actually surprisingly good at staying
alive and defending themselves.
A recent study in the journal Functional Ecology
found that certain plants, when damaged, will
emit a chemical that wards off insects.
When neighboring plants sense the chemical,
they too begin to excrete it, creating a little
smelly, defensive plant pocket.
The excretions are called “Volatile Organic
Compounds” or VOCs.
Although you may think of the word volatile
here as having a negative connotation, the
word actually means that the chemicals being
secreted are able to quickly evaporate and
enter the air.
And plants use VOCs to fulfill a lot of functions.
Sweet smelling VOCs are used to attract pollinators,
which is why some flowers give off a pleasant
scent.
Roses release volatile organic compounds like
Rose Oxide, Damascenone and ionone, which
we associate with the smell of roses.
And when it comes to defense, plants have
a few smelly tricks up their sleeve.
The VOC 3-pentanol, for example, is an insect
pheromone, and can be produced by broccoli,
cabbage, and brussel sprouts.
When these plants become infested with very
hungry caterpillars, they give off 3-pentanol,
which attracts several insects, including
what is called, the “kissing bug”, an
insect that sucks the blood of caterpillars.
Instead of having to fight their own battles,
these plants simply summon swarms of bugs
to take over for them.
Those bugs get big juicy caterpillars to feast
on, while the plants are left to recover and
rebuild, sparing any neighboring plants as
well.
Wow, way to make others fight battles for
you, PLANTS.
This natural defense system is also used by
farmers to protect their crops.
Some pesticides are based on synthetically
derived chemicals that are the same as or
mimic the chemicals produced by plants with
strong defense systems.
But chemicals aren’t the only way plants
can fight back.
If you’ve ever reached for a rose and been
stabbed by its thorns, you’ve stumbled onto
another defensive technique.
Many plants have thorns, spines, prickles,
barbs, or any other name for hard, sharp,
protruding body parts.
Their primary purpose is to prevent herbivores
from chowing down, as the spiky-defense mechanism
can hurt the predator, telling them to stay
away and find food elsewhere.
So while plants may not have wings or legs
or really any way to escape pests, they’ve
found ways to fight them with other defense
mechanisms.
All they really want is to be left alone.
So that covers animals eating plants, but
what about animal-eating plants?
Yeah, there are certain types of plants that
can eat animals from insects to small rodents!
I know that sounds crazy right, find out more
in this video right here.
And what is the most dangerous plant, in your
opinion?
Let us know down below in the comments, and
don't forget to like and subscribe for videos
of DNews everyday.